explain why men and women are not equal
go ahead Ali you want to go first we're
just not the same we're not the same and
if we're not the same then how could we
be equal so we can talk about you know
women being equal but I'm not even sure
that that's a worthwhile conversation
because there's always going to be
somebody that has advantages in
different areas compared to yourselves
men are stronger and they're bigger and
they can run faster because I don't know
if you know this but spring because it's
sprinting is more about strength like I
can't Sprint at all and then there's
things I'll beat your ass in a race
right now girl right you know and uh so
I can attest to that because a lot of
women think that they're as strong as a
man and that's that's just not
physically possible they have so much
what about in the in the workforce are
men and women equal no there should not
be professional women cry in the
bathrooms a lot I don't think men do
that my boss did
Pearl you because you and Ali both said
no immediately and then Coco took a
second she thought about it but why why
do you say when men and women are not I
didn't think about it I just didn't say
it okay well I just men and women are
different we're not the same we're
biologically different like we're just
it's not yeah well our women are
chemically different every single day so
even like I run a pretty successful
YouTube channel I have I have a show
similar like similar to this setup in my
living room and I like bring people in
and a lot of my business decisions are
run through men and I think a lot of
times you're going to find like
successful women that there's like a man
behind them helping them with the
decisions because like men are just more
logical than women because again we get
our emotions into it because we're
chemically different every single day
but the counter argument that I hear
okay is well you know men have been
running the world for years and aren't
all the wars started by men that's not
true this is the counter argument that
you hear Men start all the wars World
War One World War II French Revolution
America it's all men starting to run
Genghis Khan the Mongols they they do it
all but they also built the world boom
so they they allowed they allowed us to
enter the workforce they had to tame the
world so we could enter it like if we
were still in like the old days we would
need someone to protect us so you guys
are not male haters whatsoever your male
appreciate it no I mean shout out to the
men out there I have I've built in the
world I mean I have five brothers so
when girls say things like men are trash
men are the problem I'm like okay you
can speak for yourself like the men you
pick are the problem because I I have
five really great Brothers I have a
really great father and so if you have
an issue with men like that's a you
problem and don't put that on me by the
way that is very powerful
just because he's brother doesn't mean
he's a good boyfriend well yeah but
that's on the girl to pick you pick who
you date like if you're halfway a decent
looking girl you have a million options
if you can date so I'm not gonna when
these girls come crying to me because
they hate all the boys they they chose
to date like that's your own fault I
mean I agree with that whenever like I
have this thing called Bubble Coco do
every Tuesday and Friday and I put a
little question box and people ask me
questions and they are sending me you
know screenshots and their issues and
they're explaining what this guy did but
I'm like you're letting this happen so
let's say you have a guy who only
invites you over for Netflix and chill
and you still show up and then you're
expecting him to like put you on a
pedestal and fly you to Paris or
something but like you're letting it
happen and those are the same girls
that'll cry on Tick Tock and be like oh
boo hoo poor me and I'm like I don't
feel bad for you I don't you picked him
this must be controversial with the
women like you're friends with you grew
up with this is not like are there like
you're a woman hater you're like but I'm
a woman okay
I've picked bad guys before too I'm not
perfect but in every situation I've been
in I was like you know what that was my
own damn fault wow usually is our fault
yeah by the way that is really hard to
do whether in a relationship or in the
workforce look yourself in the mirror
and be like I gotta own this L right
here it's because of my dad every time I
try to be emotional my dad is like your
fault your fault and he's right like I
just think your lot in life it's it's
your own fault and if you end up alone
because you can't pick men like that's
on you agree agreed no objection by the
way you said that you took a second but
you said that men and women are not
equal I just never I don't like
answering that question because it's
just like
I just don't like answering it okay well
they answered it yeah all right
um we're going to go to a question in a
second to tell you but there's another
word that I really want to get your guys
opinion on uh and this keeps coming up
in the red pill Community the manosphere
and it's a word I'm like aha what does
that mean uh and that the word it kind
of makes people uncomfortable especially
women and that word is submissive okay
so as a woman as a wife Ali what does it
mean to be submissive so the word
submissive has a negative connotation on
it so what would probably be more
digestible for women's ears would be
willful cooperation if your man has a
good program and it's trusted proven and
Justified Authority in that relationship
Authority with responsibility because
he's responsible for the outcomes of the
relationship if if you have that you're
naturally going to follow and that's the
thing about it is some women talk about
you know high value man high value man
there's a lot of different components to
masculinity I can say for certain that I
don't worry about my physical safety in
the presence of my husband at all he's a
strong dude I met that guy he shook my
hand real strong he's a trained fighter
and he's also trained with weapons so I
don't I don't have to worry about that
so of course I'm like let me let me get
with this program this program is
awesome I'd like the subscription to
last for the rest of my life and that's
what women don't want to hear but well
because they haven't had experience with
it because they can't keep a man but uh
the thing about submission itself is
that it has a really convoluted
understanding you're you're a man that
you quote unquote submit to willful
cooperation you willfully cooperate with
him he has to have something bigger than
himself that is the goal and some people
break it down to religion like that's
fabulous but I know for my my
relationship my husband is not a
Believer but he believes in the greater
good of humanity and Society so he's
always trying to do good in the world so
I don't have to worry about him going
mad with power and that's also a weird
narrative that women come up with
they're like well what's gonna happen if
you give a man power like they gave us
Wi-Fi and air conditioning I think
they're doing great with power and
because they picked the wrong men to
give power to so they put that on all
men so it's like again they're putting
your poor choices on all of us just
because you can't find a man to submit
to doesn't mean we can't so right and
it's argumentative women that they
struggle with submission because women
that are coming from two parent houses
well-rounded I live in the midwest I
know a lot of women that understand that
when there is trusted and proven and
Justified Authority they're like yes I
would like your help I'm gonna go with
the flow on this one but women just
don't want to be honest that like you're
not fun to be around people are tired of
arguing with you people don't want to
people are not fighting over your
invitation at the party they would
rather you didn't go well and a lot of
like more feminine girls we prefer it
like I hate making decisions like
honestly like I hire a couple people now
and like I hate it it's a horror it's so
against my personality if I could just
have someone like do that part of the
job for me I would prefer it like it is
so much easier as a girl like working
for someone than it is like having like
managing all these people so she used
instead of the word submissive willful
cooperation yes okay I'm so confused by
that term okay so yeah I mean I would
figure you're very successful yes yes so
it would be hard to imagine applying
that work ethic but in a relationship
I'm still confused do you think you can
explain no break it down so so do you
not understand the wolf of cooperation
or the submission willful cooperation
I'm like Croatian you know so okay okay
so simple it so basically it's giving
your man Authority which is not
something that's often done in society
but give me an example okay so you're
getting dressed and your dress is a
little bit provocative maybe you're a
little bit ignorant on it he says you
know honey you're showing a little bit
much I don't know if you're aware do you
mind changing like would you argue with
him or would you put on a different
dress if I think the dress looks hot I
would wear it yeah well that's that's
making it about you and I your
relationship that's yeah the opposite of
willful cooperation okay so yeah that's
not me yeah okay so let's stay there for
a second because
um I've dated some girls that look good
in dresses and maybe they looked a
little too good and I was like you know
the whole honey my this is